so for the next session we have set up
talks about chemistry so first we have
Marquette coordinates about okay thank
you James and thank you Andrew for the
invitation to come here it's I've been
enjoying the morning and learning a lot
here and I hope I can pass on a little
of what I know to you guys and maybe
entertain you a bit in the process so
well quantum chemistry is a is is the
branch of chemistry that's concerned
with trying to predict the fate of
chemical reactions using quantum
mechanics and what I'll tell you about
today is a sort of a general overview
and then a section on density functional
theory which is the most widely used
quantum chemical simulation method and
then wave function theory and I'll
divide the talk roughly I'm in two equal
halves after the introduction okay so um
so let's go back to 1830 and amuse you a
tiny bit with them Auguste comped was a
natural philosopher and he said that
every attempt to employ mathematical
methods in the study of chemical
questions must be considered profoundly
irrational and contrary to the spirit of
chemistry and he went on that too much
mathematics would lead to a rapid and
widespread degeneration of the subject
so it appears we live in degenerate
times but anyway so I'm 1830 Amelia a
little over a hundred years later um Ian
Lewis built up the College of chemistry
at UC Berkeley he's one of the Giants in
in whose footsteps we followed and in
volume one of the Journal of chemical
physics which is perhaps my favorite
journal um he wrote in the Schrodinger
equation we very nearly have the
mathematical foundation for the solution
of the whole problem of atomic and
molecular structure this was a big
concession coming from this guy because
only about a decade or so earlier he had
developed the qualitative electron pair
theory of chemical bonding and here he
was admitting that this really needed to
you know be superseded but then he said
we require a great further development
of mathematical technique so anyway so
my job is to try and tell you a bit
about how chemists have coped with the
necessity
for a great further development in
mathematical technique and we are trying
to solve the Schrodinger equation in the
clamp nucleus approximation so this is a
nasty-looking eigenvalue problem partial
differential equation in the coordinates
of the electrons the nuclei are clamped
so they provide simply a fixed field we
have kinetic energy electron nuclear
attraction and electron-electron
repulsion and the eigenvector the wave
function needs to be an anti symmetric
function of the electron coordinates
because electrons are fermions and this
annoying Coulomb potential prevents us
separating variables alas if only we
could separate variables so if we could
separate variables the eigenfunction
would be a determinant since we can't
the eigenfunction must be a
superposition of determinants and may in
general be a very complicated one the
lowest eigenvalue a zero will be the the
objective of my talk one could worry
about excited states as well but with
1/2 hour let's simplify um and it is an
implicit function of where the clamped
nuclei are and therefore is a clamp
nuclei are allowed to move around the
lowest eigen value defines the ground
state potential energy surface and that
is the social song which chemistry
happens molecules correspond to local
minima on the potential energy surface
they are separated well different
molecular isomers are separated from
each other by saddle points which are
reaction barriers and chemical reactions
connect 1 minimum to another so if one
can solve this equation one can simulate
chemistry and over the past more than
half century chemists have become quite
good at making approximations those
approximations break down in certain
limits and those opportunity to go
beyond them and that's a part of what
people pursue in quantum computing for
quantum chemistry but nonetheless the
existing models have great value and one
piece of sort of model philosophy is
important to highlight because it's a
contrast with what's often done in the
physics community and so it's important
to be aware of it that what we do as we
solve the
long equations very precisely okay we
are not looking for an imprecise right
answer we are looking for a very precise
wrong answer why is this because we are
connecting one local minimum to another
the energy differences of the
significant thing it's not the absolute
energy we don't care at all about the
absolute energy we care only about the
energy differences so we must solve the
models precisely enough so if we first
weigh the Queen Mary and then we weigh
the Queen Mary with her captain on board
we can get the difference and one might
say that's a silly way to do things but
we haven't been able to come up with a
better one okay so um practical usage
hundreds of thousands of chemists use
electronic structures tools today
implemented in on the order of ten or
twenty large software packages some are
commercial some are public domain some
are kind of hybrids I was a co-founder
of one that's now embarrassingly a
quarter of a century old it consists of
about 10 to the seventh lines of C++
code as about 10 squared contributed by
contributors and it's open team we're in
the sense that we sell it but pieces are
that a public domain and anyone can join
our development team and incent in some
sense one needs a consortium
but together something that can do
everything that a chemist wants to do
and so and so what does a chemist want
to do well the typical applications are
trying to unravel chemical reactions
that are not so simple that an
experimentalist knows intuitively what's
happening so this is an example of a
reaction path towards the green
synthesis of the precursor PTA that goes
into plastic bottles and and it's just
showing you that there is an elaborate
set of intermediates that correspond to
local minima on potential energy
surfaces separated by various barriers
and so a student in my group worked on
unraveling this reaction pathway you can
never prove a reaction pathway is right
you can only prove it's wrong so so this
is a pathway consistent with the
experimental information and it's a
typical application of electronic
structure theory which you
some many many calculations performed
complex workflows using approximate
solutions to the Schrodinger equation
yes absolutely so this is this is
approximate solutions to the to the
Schrodinger equation with clamped nuclei
this is one particular clamping another
another and one can then walk on those
potential surfaces gradient following
your way down to local minima or or with
more difficulty going down and all but
one direction and up and one to find a
saddle point a reaction barrier which is
something like this and and so this is
just a snapshot of the kind of chemistry
people want to do this is actually a
picture of our simulation sell the the
atoms that are shown as balls and tubes
are simulated quantum mechanically and
it's embedded in a an electrostatic
framework because this happens to be
catalysis in a zeolite almost all
hydrocarbons a process through a zeolite
but anyway this is this is in some sense
a representative example
well here we have on the order of from
around 30 to 40 clamp nuclei so the
potential energy surface that we're
moving on is then roughly 100
dimensional and so gradient search to
walk on the potato step one is to solve
the Schrodinger equation get the eigen
value as a function of position the
positions of the clamp nuclei step two
is compute gradients and maybe
curvatures on that potential energy
surface and then those tools can be
deployed to search those surfaces and
with the aid of human intuition uncover
reaction mechanisms so yes so the
complexity of doing that minimization
rises as the number of atoms in the
system increases there's a combinatorial
search problem eventually but of course
chemists understand a lot about
chemistry and therefore in some sense
help avoid that combinatorial problem
okay so um so 95 percent of chemistry is
done with density functional theory so I
need to tell you something about DFT but
the future and something many ways
belongs to the 5% of problems that can't
be done with DFT one my soft one my
software collaborators as well really 95
percent of chemistry is easy well and
that means that um density functional
theory is really directed at the easy
chemistry okay so there are two branches
to the quantum chemistry family tree and
one is modeling that exponentially
complicated wave function the other is
modeling the in principle exact in
practice unknowable density functional
and both of these define model
chemistry's different approximations
different models which are solved
precisely enough that we can get those
energy differences with them the
significance we need and any
approximation balances accuracy against
feasibility in other words the perfectly
accurate result in principle we know it
we know how to get it but it's perfectly
unfeasible and the perfectly feasible
ones are often perfectly inaccurate okay
so speaking of feasible and possibly
inaccurate will turn to DFT in a minute
yeah
so how important is and experiments to
this I give I give you a reaction and
you do the calculations without looking
at experimental data in principle in
practice the way to see the progress of
chemistry is kind of a triad between
experiments simulations which are
represented here and then the abstract
concepts of chemical reactivity is sort
of a three-legged three legs of a table
supporting the table of the chemistry
yeah so experiments are very very
important in no danger of going away
especially because we're not always sure
when our approximations become
inaccurate so in other words validate
and also in a combinatorial search
problem looking on a potential surface
we're guided by the fact that the
chemistry happens so we know there must
be a low-energy path through the
potential surface to enable this
catalysis to happen it happens with a
certain turnover frequency
experimentally and one can try to then
aim to validate a candidate mechanism
against that experiments are very very
important this is polynomial scaling so
in other words the so the cost is rising
between the square and the cube of the
system size if you neglect the problem
of searching on the potential surface so
if the problem is just to compute the
energy and the force and maybe the
curvature you can certainly do it for
the system several times larger than
this and this is done on more or less
mid-level computing not not not a
supercomputer so let's spend some
minutes on DFT and well I think most of
you know this I mean I wasn't sure about
the level here but let's just say why
does DFT exist so you can avoid the
wavefunction that's the wonderful
statement of DFT if you are after the
ground state energy you don't need the
wave function so the first Homburg cone
theorem says that an exact density
functional exists the energy can be
written without approximation as a
minimizer over all physically feasible
densities a function of the electron
density and the external potential
that's the but the field of the clamp
nuclei and and you can see this exists
in terms of the electron density
directly the variational principle tells
us a sort of in principle answer to what
does the functional look like well you
begin in wave function land as a
minimizer oversee though you really
don't want to do that and then you
rearrange to first minimize over road
and then minimize over the sigh that
give rise to a given row and this is the
in principle exact functional is defined
by this very very nasty looking mapping
so that tells us two things first a
comforting theorem you can do it second
we don't want the exact functional we
can't afford it that would be worse than
solving the full many-body problem so
actually what we want the things that
are wrong just not too wrong okay so so
we are going to model a functional we
trade-off accuracy against feasibility
and and then in principle minimize over
row of our once we've made a model
functional okay so that was discovered
some half a century ago in the mid-60s
and the sad news is that no one has yet
succeeded in making a useful functional
built in that general framework so what
should go into the model the kinetic
energy the classical Coulomb repulsion
and exchange in correlation and
numerically this is the biggest term and
it has been a consistent roadblock no
satisfactory kinetic energy energy
functional exists the search for one if
one could find one that is feasible
would be would be very nice yes
the second neither if that was easy and
thank you for asking so the first one is
the is the is the functional design
problem the second is called the in
represent ability problem which row of
ours actually come from valid wave
functions not obvious which row of our
should actually be put in there so so
hence a solution to both of these
problems is con sham density functional
theory which is really a beautiful
sidestep it's a retreat from pure
density functional theory to use in fact
the wave function associated with a set
of non-interacting electrons after all
then separable 'ti surely holds and the
non interacting wave functions a single
determinant and furthermore it solves
the and represent ability problem if we
use the non interacting wave function to
represent the density well then we make
it out of the orbitals that describe the
non-interacting electrons so there's a
fictitious system of non-interacting
electrons that parameterize as ro and
will then be used to evaluate the
kinetic energy we will now use the
kinetic energy of the non-interacting
electrons hoping and in fact now
believing on the basis of decades of
experience that this is actually very
close to the kinetic energy of the real
interacting electrons so now we have
solved the problem of the kinetic energy
the NIC
biggest and we've got the classical
electron-electron repulsion we've just
got to model the exchange correlation
functional that is what modern DFT is
all about and um while a short talk is
not enough time to do any justice to
this runs on a metaphorical Jacob's
Ladder are used to classify approximate
density functions there are several
hundred widely used functionals these
days and the primordial ooze down the
bottom here is where electrons don't
even have the correct spin symmetry and
up here is the heaven of chemical
accuracy and by vague analogy with the
biblical Jacob's Ladder we climb from
the primordial ooze to the heaven
beginning with first the simple local
density approximation where the unknown
exchange correlation functional just
depends on the density at each point in
space then we rise up another step to
allow gradients of the density so this
would be exact for the uniform electron
gas that's a model system that solves
that problem you then assume transfer
ability to create the functional here we
are also exact for the slowly varying
electron gas and then we go up and we
introduce second derivative information
through the so-called kinetic energy
density tau and then we begin
more-or-less hybridizing that is
introducing increasing pieces of
wavefunction theory into the density
function also the first pieces are
dependence on the occupied orbitals at
rung four and then finally in the
kitchen sink spirit our dependence on
the unoccupied orbitals as well at wrong
five and that covers just about
everything conceivable and so this
category actually works in some sense
and here's some a little bit of data for
thermochemistry showing you rung one two
three and four diminishing RMS errors as
a function of advancing up that rung for
for for example functionals and this
game has been carried to a pretty high
level of sophistication and here's some
sort of modern results brand-new ones
really um summarizing tests of 200
different density functions over about
five thousand trusted data points
across roughly seven or eight classes of
chemical energy differences so no
absolute energies only differences
non-covalent energies this is the
sticking of molecules together both for
dimers and for clusters we distinguish
those that DFT should get right as being
easy those that DFT might not get right
by being difficult so that's the D and
the C the D here and then isomerization
energies that's rearranging a given
structure to another one thermochemistry
is breaking bonds easy and difficult and
finally the the barrier from minima to
saddle point is barrier Heights here and
what you see is if you look at the best
functional from rungs one two three four
five you see a monotonic decrease with
each step up jacob's ladder as
represented by the best functional at
each level and this top line in some
sense is the best that can be done in
2018 to my knowledge and and so there's
a root mean square error of slightly
less than one kilocalorie per mole for
barrier Heights slightly less than 1/4
thermochemistry
more like point one for non covalent
interactions and if you don't like one
Sigma errors multiplied by your favorite
multiplier to make them two or three um
Sigma and even for the difficult
problems where DFT is meant to have
problems it's also a monotonic decrease
so so in a statistical sense that is
across five thousand data points DFT is
systematically improvable by putting
additional ingredients into the
functional of course that's only for the
best functional at each level the
greater the freedom you have to design a
functional the greater the possibility
you may design a bad one and so the
worst functional at each level actually
begins to get worse as you climb upwards
because some people have made design
mistakes anyway that is some that is in
some sense my DFT perspective and issues
that are that could be addressed going
forwards one always wants higher
accuracy the accuracy I give there is
just good enough
the kinds of applications that we
typically want to do then may be of more
interest to this audience is the fact
that DFT has well recognized failure
modes it doesn't get everything right
there is so called self interaction
error that's the fact that interact that
electrons artificially interact with
themselves where physically they don't
that's a defect of the exchange part of
the functional there have been historic
difficulties now largely solved in
getting long-range dispersion
interactions and then finally of most
relevance to to you I think is the fact
that DFT begins from a single
configuration of electrons and therefore
is almost guaranteed to break down in
any problem the so called strong
correlation problems where many well
more than one and potentially many
determinants are involved and there's an
issue about design at what point is one
just playing a fitting game that's a
that's a delicate question because I
play in that in that game how many
parameters are essential can you do it
ab initio and recent functionals have
made progress on everything but strong
correlation and and it's an open
question how much better can the density
functionals ten years from now B than
the density functional Civ today but
it's a safe bet they will be better I
think it's also a safe bet they won't
solve this problem okay so let's pause
here that's the end of the DFT part and
ya know it's it's it's not done ad hoc I
mean oh well it depends on what you mean
by ad hoc it's typically done with the
agree
yeah it's typically done based on the
experience of the user so in other words
I and it's often done with some initial
validation on a problem that's a close
cousin of the one you want to solve in
order to check and see so you know so as
a developer of quantum chemistry
software I find that our users are
experimental users view quantum
chemistry codes as being like an
instrument that might be miss calibrated
and so they usually trust but verify any
other questions before I go on okay so
predicting that like h2 would not be
stable this is a bit embarrassing it's a
one electron problem so there's actually
no correlation present but if you um but
if you dissociate h2 plus you get a
potential curve that that instead of
looking like what it should look like
which is this so this would be exact the
one electron solution you get something
that looks roughly right out to about
here but as the bond stretches collapses
down here so this would be for instance
a GGA
and on so it predicts the x-axis is some
energy the y-axis is the distance
between the I'm sorry the x-axis is the
distance between atoms Y out in this
energy this predicts that to H 1/2 plus
are lower in energy than H and H plus so
it would be a little like cold fusion
it's a a source potential source of
energy um but it isn't um so yeah so
that's that's this and that's a that's
obviously an electron interacting with
itself so if you make 2h 1/2 plus s that
self interaction is reduced already so
now we'll switch gears and turn to the
second branch of the family tree
wavefunction theory and if the summary
of DFT is low cost and moderate accuracy
the summary of wave function theory is
systematically improvable at high cost
so it's a bit like applying a blunt
hammer
you know sort of an instrument that's
roughly right but not precisely right to
solve the problem of your plumbing okay
and I'll tell you a bit about
configuration interaction a couple
custom methods and I'll finish with a
couple of remarks on strong correlation
so broadly speaking we make two
approximations in quantum chemistry I've
already kind of hinted at this first we
solve the wrong equations we don't solve
the Schrodinger equation we solve
something close to it so we we typically
make an electron correlation model may
be starting with mean field for instance
and then doing either CI or C C and
secondly we don't work in the complete
basis set limit for one particle
expansions we use a finite basis because
computers thought were finite
dimensional matrices so we typically use
atom centered functions with some
maximum angular momentum on each atom
although one could use finite elements
in principle or plane waves or popular
and condensed matter physics and again
contrast with condensed matter physics
as we always keep the full many-body
Hamiltonian there's a little asterisk
here to remind me to tell you well
that's in the nonrelativistic universe
and the key virtue is systemic improve
ability and in in theory it's the right
answer for the right reason in this case
whereas in DFT it's the right answer
because we have attempted to cancel out
systematic errors as best we can okay so
there's a kind of a quick walk through a
wave function hierarchy you'd begin with
mean field theory which is well I really
should have had a squid a cubed cost and
it gets 99 percent of the absolute
molecular energy but I told you we don't
care about that and what's left over the
correlation energy is one volt per pair
of electrons if I take a chemical bond
for instance between two hydrogen atoms
I pull it apart I expose the full
correlation energy of that chemical bond
a one volt or a hundred kilojoules per
mole or 25 kilocalories per mole I make
a giant error by neglecting the
correlation so even though I've got 99
percent of the absolute energy that's
useless for chemistry you can apply
perturbation theory maybe get between
or a hundred and twenty percent of the
last 1% that's no longer useful because
DFT is more accurate oh you can do
couple cluster Siri which treats the
single and double promotions of
electrons from the mean filled into
empty orbitals self consistently that
gives you about 95 percent of the last
one percent of the energy turns out
that's still not quite good enough for
chemical accuracy you have to at least
include the three body correlations so
CCSD parentheses T or CCS DT gives you
more than 99 percent of the last 1% that
is sometimes called the gold standard of
quantum chemistry because it's about the
most expensive thing you can afford and
it has finally typically gets chemical
accuracy for problems that are not
strongly correlated alright so um so to
kind of jump back and look at the
Hamiltonian matrix in the basis of the
mean field reference hartree-fock single
double triple substitutions the mean
field is optimized to zero the
off-diagonal coupling to singles because
we have a two-body Hamiltonian the zero
coupling the triple so the leading
correlation contribution are double
substitutions and therefore that's why
there's an obsession in quantum
chemistry with double substitutions what
is a double substitution well two
electrons fluctuate transiently from
occupied to empty levels and the
amplitude for doing so drops off very
strongly with the overlap between the
occupied and empty levels if they're
expressed in real space and also fairly
quickly algebraically is out of the -3
with the distance between electron 1 and
electron 2 also in real space so the
pair correlations are localized in a
localized basis set ok so configuration
interaction is then to take a linear
trial function just as if you were
solving the Schrodinger equation with
reduced rank and that of course is
exponentially expensive to do exactly so
so you truncate and the simplest
truncation would be to include single
and double substitutions that is very
you know it treats multiple states on an
equal footing but fails to be what is
called size consistent in other words
you can't truncate CI and then get
additive energies for non interacting
systems so for instance C is d is exact
for one hydrogen molecule because
there's only two electrons so you only
have singles and doubles but if I do two
non-interacting h2s
I won't get energy additivity unless I
also include triple and quadruple
substitutions so so this is really an
unnatural form of the wave function to
make truncations
so today C is very seldom used except
for strong correlation where you're
typically not making a hard truncation
you're in fact either solving a small
full CI or selecting configurations so a
couple clusters theory is the preferred
method to truncate with and we can
rewrite the linear wave function well at
first glance it seems like we make the
problem much worse by exponentiating the
correlation amplitudes t1 through TN but
now truncation by substitution level is
size consistent and and you can you can
see that if I truncate at single and
doubles and I have the exponential here
I'm getting an accounting of triples and
quadruples so for instance t2 squared is
the interaction of the double on one
system with the double on another system
that's where size consistency and
therefore energy a nativity comes from
so so this is really a good thing to do
and is what we do do how do we get the
energy and the amplitudes well we can't
do it variational e because in fact the
expansions don't terminate so um so
instead it's done by subspace projection
you solve the Schrodinger equation in a
subspace for instance the subspace of
single and but by closing the
Schrodinger equation projecting with
single and double substitutions and also
projecting with the reference you have
sufficient equations for the amplitudes
and the energy so we now have closed
nonlinear equations great we have lost
the variational upper bound in the
process so we can't assess the quality
necessarily by that
and because we're solving in a subspace
the results will be best in the case
where our projective subspace includes
all of the important parts of the
Hilbert space so that will be the case
where the single reference is kind of
dominant so in that sense couple cluster
Theory is aiming to solve similar
problems to the ones DFT is aiming to
solve the ones where were dominated by
one configuration or again the 95% of
chemistry that in some sense is easy
meeting this criterion if you climb up
the ladder you get exactness for
increasing numbers of electrons that may
be arbitrarily entangled while
maintaining size extensivity consistency
and the cost is always polynomial but
the polynomial power is rising rather
rapidly and remember remembering that
DFT is no worse than a cubed this is
already the square of DFT and it get and
that's not good enough for chemical
accuracy so you've got to be a 7th or
8th a number of atoms so assuming that
we keep a consistent description in
terms of one particle basis for all
atoms alright then so let's just see it
in practice this is a kind of a
beautiful figure where as you walk
across the x-axis we're increasing the
one-particle basis set so this is a
triple quadruple quintuple and x2
positive don't worry about the acronyms
and as we climb up the y-axis we're
going from singles and doubles to
singles doubles triples to singles
doubles triples quadruples and so if you
start down the bottom the error
distribution represented for instance in
gray or in red depending on whether the
bases said extrapolate is so broad you
can't even see it on this scale and if
you climb up for instance in a fixed
basis you eventually reveal basis set
limitations here through a width of the
error distribution and the shift or if
you fix the basis set while not fixing
the correlation treatment you eventually
see the couple clusters singles and
doubles limit but do them together and
this is a brute-force way of
systematically approaching the right
answer for the right reason so that's
the message here a couple cluster Theory
works and
for is used all right so I'll finish
with a few remarks about strong
correlation so um so what I've told you
about so far are mostly the electron
correlations in stable molecules as
exemplified or atoms exemplified by the
helium atom so we've been attempting to
describe the fact that you don't find
two electrons in helium on the same side
of the nucleus you typically find them
on opposite sides so this is a dynamical
effect that one volt to a pair of
electrons which implies a small role for
many many configurations you have to
sweat the details to get the chemical
accuracy but we are dominated by the
mean field reference plus small
Corrections now we want to contrast this
with the situation and strongly
correlated systems where there is a
major role for more than one might be
two might be a hundred might be a
thousand a whole bunch of configurations
and this by contrast with this picture
it's a near degeneracy effect the
energies of two configurations roughly
balance are nearly degenerate and if you
have nearly degenerate configurations
they'll mix strongly in quantum
mechanics so this new degeneracy effect
is essential to be qualitatively right
and so the picture here is just the toy
example of stretching h2 it's a little
bit of a toy example in many ways it's
the the strongly correlated regime is
where the bond is partly broken that is
the electrons are still entangled but
not fully broken at which point the
electrons independent alright so what do
you do to define the essential
correlations in conventional quantum
chemistry well there are a couple of
things you may try to select the
significant configurations within
full-si I this is a little bit breaking
the chemical model philosophy that I
mentioned but nonetheless if you want to
approach the correct answer selected CI
is undergoing a renaissance and norm
Tubman who I see sitting back there has
been leading that renaissance at
berkeley and you can chat to him about
this in detail early Alavi really um
began this with his full CI quantum
Monte Carlo method
and then as well or instead you may try
to solve the full CI problem not in the
entire atomic orbital space but in a
reduced space of chemically relevant or
you might say chemically active orbitals
and those can be defined from first
principles the pairing active space
where there's one active orbital /
electrons so the active orbitals are
then half occupied by definition or the
valence active space where there's one
active overall prevalence atomic orbital
or more open-ended ly and more
dangerously you may try to choose the
chemically important active orbitals at
which point you've lost the notion of a
model chemistry and instead tried to
make a custom solution then go solve the
Schrodinger equation in the active space
and if you can do that while optimizing
the orbitals at the same time that's
called the complete active space SCF
method or casa CF and that's
conceptually and practically important
but it's not the right answer you've got
a finally correct for dynamic
correlation in order to be accurate okay
so let me summarize and stop so the
virtues of wave function based quantum
chemistry in contrast to DFT is the
systemic improve ability for a given
molecule
instead of statistically and hence the
right answer for the right reason the
challenges which which are about the
rate of convergence the kind of
excessively blunt instrument for the
delicate job of treating an interesting
molecular problem and the high rate of
increase in the cost of computation
there's lots of ongoing progress on both
fronts that I don't have time to tell
you about what I really do want to
emphasize is that strong electron
correlation is an unsolved challenge
because regardless of the progress
exponential scaling challenge basically
remains and there's much ongoing effort
within the quantum chemistry community
to seek novel approximations some of
which are inherently polynomial but it's
not clear they're accurate enough to be
generally useful so anyway um I'd like
to stop there and thank you very much
for your attention
[Applause]
one of the things that of course
inter-cell of us is dynamic so how does
the situation looks here from the point
of view of posterity in class so when
you say dynamics do you mean dynamics of
the nuclei or dynamics of the electrons
okay what happens when I start we would
normally say dynamics of the nuclei is
is a sort of a separate issue in other
words once you've solved the potential
energy surface you either walk on it or
you propagate classical or perhaps semi
classical or even quantum dynamics on it
it's a separate it's a separate issue so
none of those this is this is then the
kind of prerequisite essentially to
doing nuclear dynamics on the other hand
I did restrict myself to solving for an
eigenstate here so if your interest is
in electron dynamics and things like
strong fueled phenomena then there's a a
relatively small sub branch of quantum
chemistry that is concerned with solving
the time dependent Schrodinger equation
for many electron systems that are not
in stationary States and that would be
appropriate for modeling strong field
phenomena for instance so I to
understand the quantum chemistry people
people use quantum computers use many of
these techniques but they go to much
bigger basis sets because they have
access to them with the quantum computer
are you optimistic about that it's
approach to have any thoughts about it
um well I'm not the best person to
prognosticate on that but um but what I
would say is that the that competing
against established quantum chemistry on
its home ground of problems that are
dominated by a single configuration is
pretty tough but there is a big
opportunity for trying to do a better
job on strongly correlated problems so
so getting to the basis set limit in
quantum chemistry the one particle basis
set limit is is a problem that we have
a reasonable handle on getting to the
many electron bases set limit that is
the correlation problem is only
adequately solved at the moment for
problems where strong correlations are
relatively low ranked yeah so one could
one could say well you could then try
and make couple cluster approximations
to the wave function in the active space
so for instance on that that has been
tried and it's useful if if the level of
entanglement is not too high and if the
entanglements in the active space are
essentially full rank you might as well
do configuration interaction because
then you have to go all the way up maybe
very few people use the end of the a to
the twelfth scaling methods in practice
so really the relevant comparison is
against the eight of the seventh scaling
methods those are the thing that I
mentioned is the gold standard that is
feasible for systems up to perhaps some
fifteen or twenty atoms and you know is
quite widely used but density functional
theory is the thing which is
predominantly used so quantum computing
has the chance to perhaps attain greater
precision um
surpassed couple cross the theory but I
think I think that bigger opportunity is
where couple cluster Theory breaks down
and one more question
so for chemical reaction modeling you
first pick a model chemistry so that's
what I've concentrated on in this talk
surveying the model chemistry's then
then you have to adequately search the
potential energy surface using a mix of
human intuition chemical so-called
chemical intuition and appropriate
algorithms for maybe automated
saddle-point searching and so forth for
the non chemists in the audience what
specifically are the right problems then
to look at for finding an advantage for
a quad computer I think where do you see
the most important so typically it's the
anti ferromagnetic coupling of different
transition metals there's a variety of
examples of such systems that are well
known so one example is sort of
ferredoxin which have iron sulfur
clusters and on a given iron atom there
are either three or four unpaired spins
but the entire system spin reeked uppal
to be low spin in the ground state with
a whole bunch of low-lying excited
States that's that's an example there
are many of those
[Applause]